نحن في مستشفى كمال عدوان الذي حاصره
الاحتلال اكثر من 15 يوم واطبق عليه
الحصار ما يقابل ما يقارب سبعه ايام
بالضبط الاحتلال قام بجريمه
حرب استهدفت مستشفى جديد بعد المستشفى
الاندونيسي قام الاحتلال بحصار مستشفى
كمال عدوان تمثلت هذه الجريمه المركبه
بحصار المستشفى ومنع الامدادات عنه ثم
باقتحامه وتدمير جزء كبير من مرافق
والاعتداء على الطواقم والمرضى والنازحين
واعتقال اكثر من 70 منهم واجراء تحقيقات
ميدانيه للكوادر الطبيه اضافه الى
استخدامهم كدروع بشريه تحت تهديد السلاح
منذ بدايه العدوان يتعرض المستشفى
لاستهداف مركز يوم الخامس من ديسمبر
الجاري جرى استهداف وقصف محيط المستشفى
وبوابته الرئيسيه يوم السادس من ديسمبر
جرى قصف بوابه المستشفى ومحيطه يوم الثامن
من ديسمبر اعتلى القناصه البنايات حول
المستشفى وقاموا باطلاق النار بكثافه على
المستشفى والمباني والكوادر الصحيه
والنازحين يوم العاشر من ديسمبر تم قصف
الطابق الثاني الذي فيه النساء والتوليد
واستشهد خمسه واصيب العدد كما وتم اطباق
الحصار على المستشفى بشكل كامل واستهداف
المولدات الكهربائيه وبئر المياه يوم
الثاني عشر من ديسمبر اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال مدير المستشفى الدكتور احمد
الكحلوت ابو حسن واقتد الى جهه غير معلومه
واجبرت الطواقم الطبيه على المكوث في مب
تمهيدا لتد بقيه المباني واستمر الحصار
والتنكيل بالكوادر الطبيه والمدنيين حتى
تاريخ الس 16 عش من ديسمبر جرى خلال فتره
الحصار على المستشفى اجبار من هم فوق 16
عاما من الذكور بالنزول الى ساحه المستشفى
واعتقالهم مع الطواقم الطبيه وتم الابقاء
على اطباء معدودين من بينهم الدكتور حسام
ابو صفيه مدير مستشفى الولاده هنا الاطفال
مستشفى الاطفال تم الابقاء عليهم ومعه
هؤلاء الاطباء وسيقوم الدكتور باذن الله
عز وجل بشرح ما حصل معه يخدمون 65 جريحا
و1 طفلا في العنايه المركزه تم تجميع
النازحين والمعتقلين في حوض اعد الصح قبل
بلديه بيت لاهيه واستخدمه الاحتلال
للا وتم تعريت واذلالهم طبعا
الاحتلال ابقى على مدير المستشفى واقتاده
مره اخرى اثناء التحقيق بعد اعتقاله واطلق
الاحتلال الكلاب المتوحشه على الموجودين
ونهشت الكلاب المتوحشه احد كبار السن حفرت
جرافه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه وقامت بتجريف
محطه الاكسجين ومولدات الكهربا وبئر
المياه والارشيف المركزي والصيدليه ثم
حفرت حفره عميقه داخل المستشفى وجرفت جميع
الجثامين الشهداء
داخل اطلع
[موسيقى]
اطلعوا الاطلاق عمي على
الارض اطلاق نار في المكان ونحن نقوم
بتوثيق مؤتمر وزاره الصحه اطلاق
النار ونحن نقوم بتوثيق مؤتمر وزاره الصحه
هنا في مستشفى كمال عدوان قوات الاحتلال
تقوم باطلاق النار
بكثافه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اثناء
عقدنا لهذا المؤتمر اطلق علينا الرصاص
وخرجنا من البوابه الاماميه الى البوابه
الخلفيه مازال القناصه الاسرائيليه يتعرض
الينا بالقنص المباشر على هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي نهايه تم حفر حفره كبيره داخل
مستشفى وجرفت جثامين الشهداء هذه الجرافه
داخل الحفره وكان عددا كبيرا من الجثث
تقارب ال 12 جثه يا دكتور هناك 12 جثه
وهناك عدد مصابين هؤلاء المصابين لا ندري
هل جرفتهم الجرافه الاسرائيليه داخل هذه
الجرف هذه الحفره الكبيره ولذلك يتطلب نحن
نطالب بتحقيق دولي عاجل لهذه الجريمه
النكراء المركبه بحق مستشفى كمال عدوان
وتطالب وزاره الصحه باجراء هذا التحقيق من
قبل المؤسسات الدوليه المختصه بذلك اقدم
لكم الدكتور حسام ابو صفيه وهو المدير
الطبي الذي بقي محاصرا لاخر لحظه في هذا
المستشفى من اليوم
الاول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا من
اليوم اللي تم اطباق الحصار علينا في مجمع
كمال العدوان الطبي طلبوا من الجميع
الخروج الى ساحه هذه المستشفى ومن ثم
طلبوا من النازحين دون ال 65 عام بالخروج
مرفوعين ايدي
وقاموا بعمل مسلسل كاذب امام
اعينا الاسلحه الخفيفه واعطائها للنازحين
على هيئه مسلحين قاموا بتصويرهم امام
اعينا وهم مقلعين الملابس وبعد ذلك اطلقوا
صلاحهم وكنا نف ان هذه ما تم ما تم ما ما
تم رصده من خلالنا لهذا المشهد كنا نعلم
ان هذه المقدمه لضوء اخضر لاقتحام
المستشفى والتنكيل فيها في اليوم الثاني
قاموا ب طبعا بالنداء عبر مكبلات الصوت
بالكادر الطبي للخروج خرج اكثر من 75 من
الكادر الطبي تم اعتقالهم والتعامل معهم
بطريقه غير انسانيه ايضا تم قلع الملابس
عنهم وتم شم والضرب وعندما اذوا بعض من
هؤلاء الكادر الطبي قاموا باطلاق النار
عليه واصيب خمس من الكوادر الطبيه عندما
حصلنا في طابق واحد قاموا باطلاق الكلاب
علينا وقامت احد الكلاب بنهش جث جريح يبلغ
العمر 75 عام وللاسف في اليوم الثاني
استشهد هذا الجريح طبعا شفنا يعني الكوارث
وشفنا المصائب من الجيش الذي يدعي
الانسانيه ثم قاموا بحفل ونبش كل المستشفى
حتى الجثث لم تسلم منهم قاموا بنبش وبعد
ذلك قاموا بجلها مع الخيام اعتقد كان هناك
يعني اصوات يعني تصرخ ولا نعلم ولا يسمح
لنا بالنظر لانه اي شخص كان بيتح ان يطلق
النار عليه واعتقد ان هناك كان احياء تم
جرفهم مع الجثث وللاسف اصبحنا على مجزره
جديده كلها من ال الشهداء اللي كانوا
مسبقا موجودين يعني في ساحه المستشفى من
المصابين ومن النازحين تم جرفهم كلهم على
حد سواه
فطبعا بالاضافه الى احراق المبان المحيطه
بالمستشفى مثل الصيدليه مثل محطه الاكسجين
مثل مولد الكهرباء مثل خزنات المياه لم
يعني لم يترك لنا شيء حتى نعتاش فيه طبعا
كان هناك منشدات لادخال فقط الماء كنا كان
عندنا مواليد يحتاجون الى ح حليب لكن لا
يوجد ماء فطلبنا منهم بادخال ماء وللاسف
لم يدخل شيء لا ماء ولا شيء اصبحنا على
انسحاب بشكل مباشر ف تفاجانا بكثير من
الجرحى هم شهداء استشهد معنا اكثر من 12
جريح ورفضوا اخراجهم وبقوا معنا الطابق
تعايشنا فيه في فتره الحصار المطبق كان
علينا
حدسك لدكاتره بسرعه
ال
[موسيقى]
الا